what we want to do in this video is
figure out the mass of calcium carbonate
we need to react completely with 25
milliliters of 0.75 molar hydrochloric
acid solution and we have the reaction
here and just to remind ourselves what
we're talking about we have this
hydrochloric acid and it is dissolved in
water it is an aqueous solution the
solvent is water and this point seven
five molar tells us the molarity of that
solution it tells us the concentration
or the moles of hydrochloric acid per
liter of our entire solution and we need
to figure out the mass of this calcium
carbonate that we need to react
completely with the hydrochloric acid
solution this amount of it now before we
do any stoichea stoichiometric problems
we have to make sure that our actual
equation is balanced so let's do that
first
so on the left hand side right here
we've got a calcium that's the only
calcium and on the right hand side we
only have one calcium so everything
looks good from the calcium point of
view on the left hand side we have a
carbon here I'll do it in pink we have
one carbon here and then on the we have
no carbons here and on the right hand
side we only have one carbon everything
looks good so far on the left hand side
we have three oxygens no oxygens over
here and over here we have one oxygen
and then two more we have three on the
right hand side everything looks good so
far on the left hand side we have one
hydrogen right there and then on the
right hand side we have two hydrogen's
we have two hydrogen's here so let's to
balance it let me put two we put a two
in front of the hydrochloric acid the
aqueous solution of hydrochloric acid
now the hydrogen's bounced out and we
haven't done the chlorines yet which is
good because that would have messed up
everything if they were already balanced
but let's see now we have two chlorines
on the left-hand side how many do we
have on the right-hand side we have two
so now this equation is balanced after
we throw that we threw that two
coefficient on the hydrochloric acid
so now let's figure out what mass of
calcium carbonate do we need to react
completely with this much of a of 25
milliliters of a point 7 5 molar
hydrochloric acid solution now the whole
way to think about it is I've given this
is wow this problem is different than
everything else we've seen so far is
that I haven't given you the mass of
hydrochloric acid I haven't told you the
moles of hydrochloric acid I've told you
the amount of solution containing
hydrochloric acid and the concentration
so we're going to do is take this
information to figure out the moles of
hydrochloric acid in this reaction how
many moles do we have in this solution
and then for every two moles of
hydrochloric acid we're going to need
one mole of calcium carbonate you're
going to see that and then we just have
to figure out well you know given that
we're going to have neat half as many
moles here as there are here how much
mass is that so let's do that
so we are starting off with we're
starting off with the 25 milliliters we
have the 25 milliliters of of let me
write this point seven five zero molar
HCl solution and let's convert this to
moles of hydrochloric acid so the first
thing we need to think about is the
molarity is always expressed in in moles
per liter this is expressed in
milliliters right now so I want to get
rid of the milliliters I want it to be
in liters so I want to multiply it by
liters I'll just write it as a capital L
as litres per milliliter and we know we
have one liter per 1000 milliliters or
there's one one thousandth of a liter
per milliliters however you want to view
it that's going to cancel out that
milliliters and then we want to convert
we want to use this concentration
information to figure out to figure out
the actual number of moles of
hydrochloric acid we're dealing with so
to do that we're going to multiply it
we're going to multiply it times
0.75 0.75 zero modes moles of
hydrochloric acid per per liter of point
or I'll write this is zero point seven
five zero molar hydrochloric acid
solution so let's just let me make sure
you understand what I'm doing here I
first want to get the 25 milliliters
into liters so I'm going to essentially
divide by a thousand and the units will
work out we have a milliliters in the
numerator milliliters in the denominator
we're left with a liter on top and then
I want to convert from the solution to
the actual number of moles and if
something is a I could put a zero right
here 0.75 molar that means that there is
0.75 moles of hydrochloric acid per
liter of the solution this is just I'm
just saying you know you could call that
the solution and so this will cancel out
we have the liters cancelling out with
the leaders and then you can even say
the of 0.75 molar hydrochloric acid
solution cancels out with the of 0.75
zero molar hydrochloric acid solution
and then you're left with you're left
with let me stay in the same color 25
times one times zero point seven five
zero divided by 1000 divided by 1000
moles of hydrochloric acid and let's get
our calculator out to solve for this
right here let me get the calculator out
so that is let's see 25 times 0.75
divided by 1000 is equal to 0.01 875 so
let me write that down so that is equal
to this is equal to 0.01 eight if I want
to stick with significant digits I
really don't have any more than three
significant digit
here so I really shouldn't have any more
than three here so I could say 0.018
instead of seven five I'll just round it
eight eight moles moles of hydrochloric
acid and now we know that for every two
moles of hydrochloric acid we need one
mole of calcium carbonate so we want to
know the moles of calcium carbonate
required so let's do that so let's
multiply this times we want to we want
this thing to cancel out here we want
that to cancel out so we want we want to
know so for every mole of hydrochloric
acid or for every two moles of
hydrochloric acid we see that there for
every two moles of hydrochloric acid we
need one mole I'll do it in that same
orange color
we need one mole of calcium carbonate is
required and so these moles of
hydrochloric acid is going to is going
to is is going to cancel out with that
moles in the denominator and well you're
essentially just going to take this
number multiply it by one and divide it
by two or just essentially divide it by
two so let's do that I can just take the
original number right here divide it by
two I should only do it three
significant digits so it's really and
actually well I'll just stay with it so
nine three zero zero nine three eight
just to round it so this is equal to so
this is equal to we're left with zero
point zero zero nine three eight moles
moles of calcium carbonate calcium
carbonate required and we're not done
yet remember the question that we asked
is what's the mass of calcium carbonate
required so we need to figure out we
need to essentially multiply this times
the molar mass so we want to convert
this into grams let's convert this into
grams I'll do it I'll switch colors just
arbitrarily and to figure out put it
into grams you have to figure out the
molar mass of calcium carbonate and the
molar mass of calcium you could look up
the atomic weight of
you want a periodic table it is 40 and
then you're going to have a carbon in
there that's 12 we've seen that a lot
and then you have an oxygen which is 16
but we have three of them so 16 times 3
is 48 so is going to be 40 plus 12 plus
48 which is equal to 100 so it has a
molar mass of 100 so x times 100 100
grams of calcium carbonate for every for
every well let me just write that grams
of calcium carbonate for every mole of
calcium carbonate and we know we're
doing the right thing by multiplying by
100 because these units cancel out moles
of calcium carbonate in the numerator
moles of calcium carbonate in the
denominator so those cancel out so we're
essentially just have to multiply this
thing times 100 so let's do that so that
thing times 100 so times 100 is equal to
and we had rounded it so it's 0.9 3/8 so
let me write that point nine three eight
so it equals 0.93 eight grams of calcium
carbonate